this is what the future of motoring
looks like
battery packs instead of internal
combustion engines and at nissan
it's going to become the norm archer's
announced a 1 billion pound project with
partner envision
to bring a new all-electric model and a
massive new gigafactory to sunderland
the government has contributed around
100 million pounds to the project
accelerating the journey to
electrification set out by the prime
minister
by increasing the number of batteries
we can make in the uk uh increasing the
number of electric vehicles we can make
getting those economies of scale
we're going to need so that the price of
of ebs
comes down and they become more
affordable
uh for for families than than petrol
vehicles
as recently as last year nissan warned a
no deal brexit could see it leave the uk
altogether
but taxpayer support has secured a
remarkable
vault fast government is a vital part of
our
ecosystem but what i want to say is
nissan ev360 is the demonstration
of renaissance of the british car
industry
nissan will add around 900 staff to the
6000 already employed here and the
gigafactory to be built next door
powered by 100
renewable energy another 750 with
thousands more working in the supply
chain
this may be a green revolution in
motoring but it's driven by economic
necessity
by 2030 new petrol and diesel
cars of the sort they built here for 35
years will be banned and before then
the brexit deal means that the batteries
for electric cars
will have to be made here in the uk or
europe otherwise they will attract
tariffs when they're exported even with
nissan's commitment the uk will still
lag behind the competition in battery
manufacturing
measured by gigawatt hours the power
produced
by 2025 the uk will have 12 gigawatt
hours of capacity
behind sweden hungry poland and germany
which will have 10 times as much
by 2030 the gap with europe will have
widened with just 37 gigawatt hours of
planned capacity in the uk
compared to 640 in the eu
the government is also in talks with
vauxhall to bring an electric vehicle to
its ellsmere port plant
and ministers are confident a positive
announcement could come soon
nissan's commitment is unalloyed good
news for the north east
it needs to jump start uk battery
production
if britain is to win the race paul kelso
sky news in sunderland